hello america
the folks at wonderful pistachios have
asked me to help sell their product so a
few years ago stephen colbert made this
commercial but come on
they're wonderful
i'm wonderful
they'll sell themselves he's sitting at
sort of a prestigious looking wooden
desk he's looking his usual dapper self
dressed in a suit and his glasses
and in front of him sitting there is one
bag and one bowl of pistachios so it
takes about one gallon of water to grow
one of those pistachios sitting in that
bag on cober's desk
you mean one bag of pistachios no no
one nut
i'm sorry what statue wait for it
pistachio
yep
so an eight-ounce bag has about
170 nuts
that's about 170 gallons of water
and the wonderful company grows not only
pistachios but also almonds lemons limes
mandarins and pomegranates
and that means they're using an
estimated 150 billion gallons a year
or two thirds of that on nuts
[Music]
i'm your host michaela tandera and this
is priceless
in this episode we're headed west to the
epicenter of one of the most productive
farming regions in the world
california's central valley
where the area is in the throes of a
mega drought that has been drying up
wells and damaging crops across the
western united states
it's there in the central valley where a
billionaire couple own a majority stake
in one of california's largest water
storage facilities
in a time and place where water and
reliable access to it are paramount it's
an asset that if sold could be one of
the hottest auction items of the next
decade
we estimate that it could be worth as
much as three billion dollars
and counting
we're going to explain how we got to
that number and how as climate change's
effects intensify
that figure is likely to only go up
to help us with this story i am joined
by chloe sorvino she leads forbes food
and agriculture coverage and started
reporting on this back in 2014. hi chloe
hi thanks for having me so
the owners of the wonderful company are
a married billionaire couple named
stuart and linda resnick and they've
held a spot on our forbes 400 list of
wealthiest americans for the last decade
now you may not know them by their names
but you've certainly seen the brands of
their wonderful company in the grocery
store and on television wonderful halos
sweet seedless easy feel
wonderful pistachios get cracking palm
wonderful the antioxidant superpower
fiji water is a gift from nature to us
by their own estimates half of american
households buy their products
their company brings in about five
billion dollars in annual revenue based
on that we estimate that stewart and
linda resnick have a net worth of eight
billion dollars today
linda resnick who's been called a
marketing genius
grew up in beverly hills the daughter of
a hollywood film producer
she dropped out of college and started
her own ad agency at 19.
and stuart who grew up in new jersey
moved out to california to attend ucla
he met linda when he came to her as a
client in 1970. he needed help with
advertising for his janitorial service
within the decade they were married and
in 1978 stewart bought his first parcel
of farmland in california as a hedge
against inflation
and so began their agricultural empire
much of their ability to grow that
empire to where it is today has hinged
on their access to water and lots of it
before we get into how the resnicks get
their water it's important to understand
the unique water system that their
business operates in in california
yeah california has one of the most
sophisticated and complex water delivery
systems in the world exactly
california captures about three quarters
of its snow and rain in watersheds
located north of sacramento meanwhile
about 80 percent of the demand for water
comes from the bottom two thirds of the
state
to accommodate the uneven supply and
demand the government got involved and
ultimately a number of delivery systems
were built including the state water
project and the central valley project
each one through an intricate series of
canals dams and reservoirs transports
water hundreds of miles down the state
it is pretty remarkable those changes to
the environment have brought about their
own new challenges within local
ecosystems but without this type of
infrastructure farming in the valley
couldn't be what it is today
farmers need access to water to reliably
irrigate their crops farmers in
california either have land with water
that's pumped from the ground or they
get it by diverting it through a stream
california is a really dry and hot state
it's drought prone
and that's where some technology comes
in in the central valley drip irrigation
systems are common they often use
sensors and deliver water directly to
the roots in the ground
but when there's a drought the state has
trouble delivering as much as promised
if farmers groundwater dries up or they
can't get enough from the state they
pretty much have to buy from a neighbor
or a water district selling it privately
[Music]
in 1988 california was one year into a
six year long drought
when the california department of water
resources bought lands in kern county
for 31 million dollars from the
conglomerate teneco west over the next
few years the department spent millions
more on additional construction
environmental and water quality studies
during much of that time the drought
continued on in 1994 some of stuart
resnick's most trusted advisors met with
several leaders in the southern
california water districts and other
state water officials
and this is exactly the setting where
they brokered a deal known as the
monterey agreement
that agreement set up a public-private
partnership where the state handed over
that public land and underground aquifer
to a group of five public water
districts and a company set up by the
resnicks called west side mutual water
the new owners agreed to give up their
state water contracts and then paid to
install a six mile long canal and 85
wells at a cost of 50 million dollars
and more than two decades later it still
gives them nearly unrivaled access to
water storage
[Music]
some critics have called the meetings
that led to the monterey agreement
secret and the resnick's ownership has
been challenged in court numerous times
but as chloe reported in 2015 the
wonderful company denies the meetings
were done clandestinely and has alleged
that those who say so have a quote axe
to grind to be candid with you maybe
this is a little bit
maybe i'm being you know a little
pollyanna but
that's stuart resnick from an interview
chloe did with him back in 2015.
we established this water bank 20 years
ago
and we did everything
by the rules
and it's kind of like
i was telling steve earlier it's like
when i first came to california 60 years
ago i should have bought property on
rodeo drive
you know a lot of other people did i
didn't
now with rodeo now i'd like to go back
and buy the property on rodeo drive for
the same price it was 60 years ago okay
i can't do that well the people that had
opportunities to buy in the water bank
just like we did
they didn't think it was worthwhile at
that point in time now they think it's
worthwhile so
20 years ago we did it we've been sued
for 20 years and we've won every lawsuit
[Music]
you know one of the things about the
resnicks is that they're actually
following a well-beaten pass since the
19th century
that's char miller he is the w m keck
professor of environmental analysis and
history at pomona college in claremont
california of those who have tremendous
monetary assets
who have tried and often succeeded
although some have failed spectacularly
to
corner the market effectively of water
and understood again in the 19th century
that land
tied to water is the most profitable
investment you could possibly make
so if you go back in time the resnicks
look like everybody else except they're
just doing it in a more spectacular
fashion
in the 21st century because they
effectively control
the largest groundwater
water bank certainly in california and i
suspect in the united states as well
still it's worth noting that
public-private partnerships of this kind
are quite rare in the united states
today
according to a 2020 report from the
congressional budget office
public-private partnerships that provide
transportation and water infrastructure
have represented just one to three
percent of such projects since the early
1990s
[Music]
from above
the current water bank looks sort of
like a gigantic shallow pond
it spans some 20 000 acres which if
you're unfamiliar with what acreage
actually looks like
it's roughly the size of the entire
island of manhattan
and
underground it has the capacity to store
some 1.5 million acre feet of water
an acre foot is just the weird
measurement in the world of water that
is used as like the most basic
measurement so it means it's the amount
of water that it takes to cover one acre
of land with one foot of water one acre
foot is the equivalent of
326 thousand gallons of water
and so
1.5 million acre feet is about 500
billion gallons of water
these are really big numbers to try to
picture so let's think about it this way
two acre feet would fill up an olympic
sized swimming pool
so that means that this water banks
capacity is the equivalent of
750 000 olympic sized swimming pools
well that's still sort of hard to
picture so let's think about it another
way
the jaclyn kennedy onassis reservoir in
new york city's central park holds about
1 billion gallons of water
so the kern water bank holds the
equivalent of some 500 central park
reservoirs
and thinking about it one other way the
city of san francisco uses about 70
billion gallons annually
so the kern water bank can hold roughly
a decade's worth of water for the entire
city
the water bank is often described as if
you picture a giant bathtub and fill
that with sand
in wet years water is collected and
stored there where it can percolate and
stay put until it's needed in drier
times and it's pumped out for municipal
industrial and agricultural purposes
it works like a bank in the wet years
they fill it up as much as possible
while of course also still watering
their crops with whatever they can and
in the dry years when there's not a lot
of access they cash in on what they
previously stored where the current
water bank is is where the um current
river would peter out
that's lois henry she's the ceo and
editor-in-chief of non-profit newsroom
sjv water so
it is naturally an excellent uh
groundwater recharge area because over
the millennia you just you know it was
it was built up with sand and gravel and
you know all that good stuff rather than
clay which is hard to you know percolate
water through so it's it is naturally
the best place to recharge water
lois is the expert when it comes to
water in california the centro valley is
the place where water impacts every day
life they have been underserved for
years and lois knows that so deeply
she's one of the few journalists who has
kept an eye on these crucial issues for
years
current groundwater bank continues to be
i think the absolute jewel of
banking and recharge in california bar
none and that means it's the best in the
world because if you're the best in
california you're the best in the world
i have five farms and underneath all my
farms runs a big giant aquifer that's
like an underground lake that's so cool
pumping rights
that means i get to take the water
all right it's very important because
someday water is going to be more
precious than gold and people are going
to kill each other to try to get that
water oh hey hey
bare hands don't try again
don't listen right right sorry but i'm
gonna have to water
and i'll share with you
that's the character connor roy from the
very first episode of the hit hbo series
succession if you haven't seen it it's
about the fictitious billionaire roy
family whose fortune stems from a
massive media and entertainment empire
they have all the trappings of a
billionaire family the yachts the
helicopters the countryside estates so
of course it's no surprise that one of
the roy family members might also hold a
stake in something with as much
potential for value as water
the current groundwater bank is a huge
huge asset that's lois again i i mean
it's almost incalculable to see to to
understand how
valuable it is but in fact that's
exactly what chloe set out to determine
how much is the resnick's stake in kern
worth
they were originally super excited about
having me out at least that's what i was
told chloe first started looking into
the value of kern water bank back in
then the next year when she was
reporting a forbes magazine feature on
the couple and california was in the
midst of its previous drought
she made a plan that summer to go out to
california to see the wonderful
company's farming operation in person
i was also told that i would get to have
a private plane ride from la to the
central valley to tour their farms their
processing plants and have
the full shebang but you know as i
started digging more and more into their
water rights all the water valuations
and how they really control so much
water in california and as my questions
kept on coming eventually they pulled
all of that back
so instead she took a different approach
i convinced a friend of mine who works
at apple to drive me about two and a
half hours from la into the central
valley
a lot of the fields are visible from
public streets in the main highway so i
saw a lot of the trees and orchards that
way and spent a lot of time in some of
the public parks and surrounding areas
which they fund
the drought was really raging it was dry
everywhere except for this super super
lush land which was their orchards
there were little tumbleweeds almost
everywhere i could see even though if
you got into the orchards they were
using a lot of drip irrigation and so
there would be grasses and lush areas
right around the root systems of these
trees
that fall back in 2015 in chloe's
magazine feature she reported that amid
the drought that was happening then the
resnicks had an estimated 57
stake in the current bank that was worth
at least 250 million dollars
so
how did she come up with that estimate
owning water or access to water storage
is a pretty weird thing and experts like
lois have called it incalculable
or priceless but i really want to try to
put a price tag on it because
theoretically if the resnicks decide to
sell their stake in the water bank it
could be one of the hottest auction
items of the next decade and my god the
bidding war would be intense that's char
miller again
they hold all the cards
or 57 of them anyway
and that gives them an extraordinary
hold over a really precious
valuable resource
in a place that has been profoundly and
importantly one of the bread baskets of
the united states or at least the fruit
basket and nut basket of the united
states that it seems to me would bring
in not just outside capital from
california but international capital
because to get that 57 percent or some
version of it in a climate charged world
is
frankly priceless
[Music]
to determine the water bank's potential
value i looked at two figures the bank's
capacity and the price that water is
selling for
so we already know that the kern water
bank reports its total capacity at 1.5
million acre feet or about 500 billion
gallons of water
but what about the price of water
water prices aren't really listed
anywhere like a price tag on an item at
a store
they also really vary based on location
time of year and drought conditions i've
been asking around about
prices and people are getting really
kind of cagey about what what they're a
paying for you know water and be what
they're trying to sell it for because
now it's getting really desperate
lois explained that if a private company
or landowner is buying or selling water
sometimes she can find in her own
reporting a paper trail left in the
public record
we spoke with her over the summer and
she said this
i can find out how much water was moved
but the actual monetary deal was made
landowner landowner and that's quote
private according to their attorney
on the low end during wet years
especially you can buy water for roughly
250 per acre foot in southern california
so with that market price the potential
value for the bank at a capacity of 1.5
million acre feet would be roughly 375
million dollars
and accounting for the resnick's 57
percent ownership stake their piece
would be worth about 200 million dollars
but obviously 2021 has not been a wet
year in california
back in may lois henry reported for sjv
water that the price of water was
trading from 425 dollars per acre foot
up to one thousand dollars per acre foot
based on a thousand dollar per acre foot
price that would put the total value of
the bank at 1.5 billion dollars or the
resnick stake would be worth about 850
million dollars
and in the height of the summer's heat
chloe said that she heard prices could
go for all the way up to two thousand
dollars per acre foot that price would
send the potential total value of the
bank if all the water was in it
all the way up to three billion dollars
if the resnicks were ever able to sell
their stake in the bank at that price
they could net 1.7 billion dollars and
of course with climate change access to
water storage like this is only going to
get more and more important and more and
more valuable
i recently reported that precipitation
in the sierra nevada mountains which
californians like the resnicks rely on
for water is expected to drop by 40
percent over the next century
with that expected drop in precipitation
char miller believes our valuation of
the water bank is quite conservative and
it's conservative because of what we
expect to happen what is happening
across the entire southwest but in this
case in california equally that the rest
of this century is going to be more dry
than wet that means that water becomes
more valuable rather than less and if
you're holding as the resinics are 57
of current water bank and that's the
that's the only thing we're looking at
here that value
in the future is astronomical
so
one would think that only going on
current value tells us one set of data
gives us one sort of calculation
but i would argue that over the next 10
to 15 years that calculation will in
fact be much much higher
fields are left fallow
orchards are removed
number of fires and area burned are
extensive
fish rescue and relocation begins
pine beetle infestation occurs
survival of native plants and animals is
low
wildlife death is widespread
algae blooms appear
this may sound like something out of a
post-apocalyptic novel
but actually it's the description from
the u.s drought monitor of the type of
drought that nearly one half of
california experienced this year
and of course this type of drought means
if you need water
you'll likely have to pay dearly for it
despite the wonderful companies access
to this water bank and the
implementation of water saving
irrigation techniques
chloe reported in 2015 that amid that
drought the wonderful company expected
their own production of almond trees to
drop 20 percent and pistachios to drop
60 that year how could this be possible
how could an agricultural business have
access to a water source that has the
capacity to fulfill the city of san
francisco's water needs for several
years and not have enough for its own
orchards
according to the kern water bank
authority the water bank is for the
benefit of its members and their
constituents including more than 400
farmers and tens of thousands of
residents in bakersfield in kern county
in september a representative from the
current water bank authority told us
that the water bank was about two-thirds
of the way full of water however the
water bank has an annual pumping limit
of 240 000 acre feet per year or about
78 billion gallons
that limit is in place for a number of
ecological reasons but mainly it's
because if too much water is pumped out
too quickly the ground literally starts
to sink that's known as a process called
subsidence it also means that all of the
kernbank's users can only remove about
15 percent of the bank's capacity every
year but as we mentioned at the
beginning of the episode we estimated
that wonderful's agricultural operation
uses about 150 billion gallons of water
per year a number that wonderful says is
high but didn't elaborate more that's a
severe limitation on what stewart
probably hoped decades ago would have
been unfettered access to water
while the current water bank plays an
integral role in the wonderful company's
ability to store water most of the
company's water comes from long-term
contracts and other water from land
rights they've had from farms they own
some of that may get pumped and stored
in the current water bank
around nine percent of the total water
used by the wonderful company is bought
out on the open market while that's not
a huge amount of the water that
wonderful uses the company can outspend
pretty much every other farmer in the
region and has the ability to influence
water prices
a spokesperson for the wonderful company
told forbes in an email quote
like all farmers we occasionally need to
purchase water for our crops
however we prioritize water rights when
purchasing farmland thus most of our
supply is not purchased on the water
market based on this we do not believe
we have enough purchasing power to
impact water prices
while stewart and linda resnick are some
of the most dominant players in western
water
they are hardly the only billionaires
interested in water and water rights
in the last year bill gates who is one
of the largest landowners in the country
reportedly lost out in a bidding war
between his investment firm and the
mormon church to buy up thousands of
acres of land in washington state that
included water rights
the water bank has been a critical asset
for wonderful over the decades
but climate change makes sewer and linda
resnick's majority ownership of key
water conservation infrastructure
even more contentious
at this point
who else might be able to control this
kind of asset other than a billionaire
thanks for listening to priceless
this episode was reported by me michaela
chandera and chloe sorvino
it was co-produced by me and jonathan
palmer
and additional research by sue ratlauer